Herkese merhabalar ben Türkiye'nin en
derin magazin çukuru şoka topun sahibi
Bugün sizinle burada görüntülü ve sesini
dizerek yere geldim dahi videolarımda
görmüş olduğunuz gibi
Ya sen neden sesimde yüzümü gizlemeyi
tercih ettim çünkü çıktığımda Benim de
içimde Türk'ü sizler için de olduğu gibi
ya da ya mesajlarla ve emellerle tek
seneden şok hop gibi bir orada diye
yazan insanların da içinde olduğu gibi
benim de içimde magazine burun kıvıran
böyle Elif de gidip bir ses var Bunlar
boş işler yani bunlarla uğraşıyorsun
denebilecek olma korkusuyla Bu yola
çıkarken yüzünü görsem izlemeyi tercih
ettim sizlere içindeki magazin polisinin
sebeplerini daha iyi anlatabilmek için
öncelikle kendimi daha yıkıntı bilmem
gerekiyor ama bunun için de Öncelikle şu
an sürü ve kaldırmak istiyorum ki daha
rahatsızlık ediyorum Merhabalar benim
adım Ekim Acun şok topun çukurunu O
ellerin magazin çukurunu k
O benim Bundan tam olarak iki sene önce
videolarımı çekip kurgulayıp yayınlamaya
başladım tek başıma bugün 2020'nin şubat
ayının 29'unda geldiğimizde şoka pişi
bir şirkete dönüştü Benim bugün bir
ekibim var ve beraber çok güzel işler
üretebiliyoruz bir anlamda bir şirket
kurduğum için marka isimtescilden tutun
iş toplantılarına kadar tabii ki
toplantıları maskesiz gidiyorum Yani
aslında geçtiğimiz Bir senede bu oyunu
kişi Biraz yalan oldu ama iki sene çok
güzel bir şekilde kotarmış doldurdum
Bugün ben neden maske takarak başladı mı
anlatırken bir yandan da beraber neden
magazin ilgimizi çekiyor aslında bir
yandan ve Yani bu bizim suçluluk
duyduğumu zevkimiz Bugün flash plajımız
Neden ben magazin bunu hep beraber
düşünebilirim istiyorum Bunun için de
size kendi hayat hikayesini anlatarak
başlamalıyım ben bin 900
bu yılında Dersim'de doğdum daha bir
yaşını doldurmadan onbir ayda İstanbul'a
taşındık ve orta halde iki çocuklu bir
ailenin en küçüğü olarak İstanbul
Anadolu Yakası'nda büyüdüm ben büyürken
Yani bugün şimdi 90'lara baktığımızda
benim ve ekibimin hazırladığı videoları
izlediğinizde 90'lar çok tatlı gözüküyor
çok şeker gözüküyor ama ben büyürken
Gerçekten böyle değildi son derece
karanlık bir politik film vardı 90'larda
Ve bu bizim evimizin tam ortasında
yaşanıyordu Annem de babam da Sol
görüşlü insanlar ve kendi değerlerine
son derece sağlıklı insanlar kişisel
özgürlüklere çok değer veren insanlar
olmalarına rağmen büyük en bu boyalı
basılı olan ilgimi devamlı Bastırmam
gerekli Çünkü asla kabul görmüyordu
boyalı basın diyorum Çünkü ailemin ev
aldı gazete 90'larda bile diyeyim yani
baştan sonra siyah beyaz sayfalardan
oluşan sadece başlığı kırmızıydı
bu ve televizyon sayfası bile gerçekten
aşırı sıkıcı yani böyle filmlerin
beğenip beğenmeme oranına göre
verdikleri şöyle gülümseyen yüzü de aynı
ve şu böyle Duran böyle çizgi ağzı bir
tane sürat vardı benim içimde o
gazetenin ciddiyeti gerçekten çizgi ağzı
sürat kadar böyle renksiz böyle Nemrut
bir o kadar da karanlıktı Diğer taraftan
90'larda o gürül gürül Coşan özel
televizyonlar sayesinde televizyonda
gördükleri bir o kadar renkliydi bir o
kadar eğlenceliydi E tabii ki bir çocuk
olarak ben renkli tarafı seçtim ama
bununla beraber o çocukluk yıllarımı
atlatma ve aile yaşantımda bu ilgilerini
kabul ettirmem Beni buna bastırmayı
bitti ben Çocukluğumda hafta sonları
Gazete almaya yollandığında o Siyah
beyazlı gazetenin içine renkli magazin
eklerini gizleyerek sokağın bir çocuktum
aynı şekilde okuldan eve dönerken de
çeşitli magazin dergi ve Gazeteleri alıp
çantanın içine koyup gelip
Bu da böyle abur cubur yerken gizlice
ailemden sırtımızdan ederken bu magazin
yayınlarını okumaktan son derece keyif
alıyordum en sevdiğim anlarım bunlardı
bu kadar bir şeyler gizlenince ya da
daha doğrusu bir şeyler böyle
yasaklanınca bir o kadar da ilginizi
çekmeye başlıyor bir zaman sonra ve
onlara karşı iyice bir tutkuyla
bağlanıyorsun zannediyorum Bu benim için
de böyle gelişti ve gerçekten o dönem
okudum ne varsa Kim kiminle nerede nasıl
ve ne şekilde olduğuna dair herşey
Hafızama yerleşti ve bunlar benimle
beraber kala kaldılar Ne yapacağımı
bilemedim Bir çok gereksiz bilgi ile
donatılmıştı mama benim için bu bilgiler
o kadar da gereksiz değildi Hepsi Bir
anlama çıkıyordu hepsi bir yere
vuruyordu bugünkü halini gördüm bir
kişinin bir olayın bir durumun Geçmişte
nasıl olduğuna dair bilgim vardı Ve bu
olayları Bir tık daha enteresan
araştırıyordu benim için güncel magazin
takip ederken şimdi bu yıllarda daha
böyle biraz da akıl vermeye orta okul
zamanı geçtiği zaman artık aileme Hani
Çünkü önüne geçemez
bu topla Küreğin var ya yatağın üstü
kocaman bir Buffy The Vampire Slayer
yatak örtüsü Duvarımda bir sürü poster
Kapında bile postalar vardı ve bunu
yutulabilir bir şekilde hayatta
kalabilme devam ederek yaşam olaydım o
aile ortamı içerisinde ve ben de bir
Popüler Kültür kesmesinin Burada beni
kurtarabileceğini çok erken keşfettim
ortaokul yıllarımda sinemaya ilgi
duymaya başladım Türk sinemasının
özellikleri ve yönetmen olmaya karar
verdim soyadım aleme ona da benim benim
bu konuda sağolsunlar çok desteklediler
ancak benim yapmak istediğim Yönetmenlik
onları bildiği ve saygı duyduğu işte
Yılmaz Güney ya da da Nuri Bilge Ceylan
çizgisi değildi bu ikiliye dikkat
filmini bayılıyordum Banu Alkan ve
Serpil Çakmaklı başrolünde oynadığı
benim için bir gerçekten kapıda Follow
bir başyapıtı benim için bu film buçuk
uğraması düştüğümde anlatayım size tam
olarak o dönemler As geliyor bir gece
Zaga programını izliyorum
bu izlemekte karışmadığı Okan Bayülgen
olan beylerinden herhalde Olsa Gerek
Okan Bayülgen o programda Banu Alkan ve
Serpil Çakmaklı bir arada çıkarttı ve 15
sene o tarihten 15 sene önce çekilmiş
bir film hakkında inanılmaz bir muhabbet
çevirdiler yani işte sahibi geçmişinden
utanıyordu babamın olmaz savunuyordu
Okan hepsiyle dalga geçiyordu ama günün
sonunda 15 sene önce yaratılmış bir eser
hakkında Gerçekten hepimiz eğlendirecek
üç saatlik bir Yayın gerçekleştirdiler
ve benim gerçekten şöyle bir adamım
açıldı O hafta galiba program çok
gizlenmiş olsa gerek aynı kanalda bana
Akan filmleri öldürülmeye başlandı Ben
hepsini Teker teker oturdum izledim ve
birkaç hafta içerisinde odamlar sevgili
kuzenim yaprak banklı ve İstiklal
Caddesi'nde Atlas Pasajı'nda Sibel
Gökçe'nin Sibel Gökçe isimli bir bootie
vardı ve çok güzel enteresan kıyafetler
bulunabilen ben oraya götürdü yanında ve
gitmişken de bak pasajın arkasına
Gitsende orada tam senlik bir dükkan var
dedi
ben oraya gittim ve bir baktım Atılgan
diye bir dükkan hemen böyle girişinde
bitiminde Dünyayı Kurtaran Adam filminde
Cüneyt Arkın'ın sakin oynayan Aytekin
akıllı yediği kostüm duruyor ve böyle
içeride bir sürü vhs kaset bir sürü
dergi bir sürü bir sürü çizgi roman Neye
uğradığımı şaşırdım ve Adam bana ne
istiyorsun Niye geldin buraya ben de
işte bu filmleri merak ediyorum falan
dedim ve bağlı Akan filmleri sordum Oda
bana karşında ya onları da izlersiniz
sen önce bir şunları izleyip Türk yapımı
şeytan filmi ve Drakula İstanbul'da
filmini vhs kasete çekip verdi ve beni
yolladı ben ondan sonra daha fazlası
için gittim Daha fazlası için gittim o
bana Her seferinde Balkan filmi vermek
yerine kendi zevkine uygun olarak
fantastik Türk sineması örneklerinden
vermeye başladı onlar da beni bir o
kadar eğlen diyordu ama ben hala bu işte
Banu Ahu Serpil şeytan üçgeninden
çıkamıyor dum nihayetinde beni Aslan
Pasajı'nda başka bir veya seciye
Bu arada oraya gidip gelmeye başladım O
pasajda bu sefer plakları keşfettim sene
2300 alan filmin çıkmasını yaklaşık altı
sene var ve plak fiyatları inanılmaz
ucuz kimse almıyor Ben ve XL Plus
insanlar odan hem de ben Örneğin Ajda
Pekkan Süperstar 83 planı 20 milyon
aldım yani benim okul için bana verilen
açlıktan O bir günlük alıp
kullanabileceğim kadar bir para ya o
dönemde bu Türkçe plakları eşli
biliniyordu ve ardından işte bir kapım
olması gerektiği onu hallettim bilmem ne
ya bu sefer İşte bu Veya senin yanına
bir de plak eklendi yine bu sahaflara
Gide Gele bu sefer dergiler bu işin
içine girdi tam o zaman da müzik
eleştirmeni ve popüler kötü tarihçesini
indirmeler Bak Bir Varmış Bir Yokmuş
kitabını çıkarttı Türkçe pop müziği
tarihini anlatan ve 90'larda 13 bir
çocuk olarak benim için pop müzik Yonca
Evcimik'in abonesi ile başlıyordu bunun
böyle olmadığını çok çok
ne olduğunu 70'li yıllarda 60'lı
yıllarda nasıl bir Türkiye olduğunu Hem
bu albümlerden teker teker bahsederken
aynı zamanda sanatçılardan ve onların
diğerlerinden bir yandan da kitabın
içinde şöyle her bir sayfada ufaklık
notlarla o dönem Türkiye'de neler
yaşandığını tasvir ediyordu ve benim
için çok ilginç geldi Mesela sana şu
anda yok o yüzden söylemde sakınca ama
dünya Gençlik Merkezi bir yer vardı Ben
Küçük Ağa bayılıyordum yani böyle içinde
en güzel şeyler bulunuyordu Örneğin onun
açıldığı haberini okudum yakın
zamanda açılmış olsa düşünce 10 Sn 15
sene önce falan açılmış dedim e Türkiye
Bunun öncesinde nasıldı ne tip bir yerde
benim annemin babamın büyüdü atmosfer
Nasıl bir şeydi bu sefer onlara buna
dair sorular sormaya başladım ve bütün
bu çerçeve böyle giderek genişleyerek
hayatıma hakim olmaya başladı Ben
yönetmen olacaktım ve sinema okuyacaktım
Hakkı tanesine okudum ve yönetmen olarak
bölümünü bitirdim ama yönetmen olmadım
eğitimi bilgisayarda aldım ve
yurtdışında olduğum sürede de
ve İngiltere'deki Okulu'nda ilk
başladığım günden itibaren müthiş bir
hocam oldu Kanadalı bitirme atıyoruz
konteks Usta diz dersimize geliyordu Ve
bize daha ilk dersten Sizin sinema
ilgilisine planınız nedir diye sordu
hemen ardından da galiba benim içimi
rahatlatan faktör olarak şu geldi
kendisini planını anlattı brainpop
almanın son derece Berbat ama bir o
kadar da güzel kedi diye bir filmi
vardır ve kendin sonunda ona tuzak Kuran
okuldaki kötü işte zorba arkadaşları
Canon başından aşağı oprom gecesinin
sonunda bir kova kandöker lar ben
sevgili 50 küsür yaşında ki o camın en
sevdiği ve işte sinefil Hanım bu benim
diye tarif ettiği Hanım bu olmasıyla ben
de o zaman bize de yapacaksınız g Çünkü
ödev varmışlardı ben de o zaman bu ki de
dikkat üstüne yazacağım dedim bağıyla
Serpil O bir araya geldi ve konuştukları
anlayabilir yazacağım yazdım Hocam çok
beğendi sonra biz onu muhabbet falan
etmeye başladık sonra ortaya çıktı ki
yalan üzerine izliyormuş
Evet şu anda ve günlük pembe sizleri çok
seviyor sonra yalancılık karakterleri
bende biliyorum çünkü anneannemle
izliyorduk yani çocuk ya ve Fark etmedi
Türkiye'de biz 10 sene önceki bölümleri
izlediğiniz için onun izlediği dönemle
Benim Türkiye'de izlediğim dönem
birbirini bir şekilde tutmuş onu
üstünden daha da birbirimizi tuttuk ve
sağolsun onu bu yönlendirmeleriyle ben
kendi içimdeki bu bu işlere burun
kıvıran işte ben bunu yaparsam zaten
kabul görmem Herkes bana küçümseyerek
bakar diyen sesi giderek sustura bilmeyi
öğrenmeye başladın diyeyim üniversiteyi
tamamlar tamamlamaz İngiltere'de Ankara
Antlaşması yaptım ve tam da böyle yeni
sigortalı ve gerçekten Düzenli bir
geliri olan işe ihtiyacım olduğu noktada
Ankara Anlaşması şartlarından ötürü
filan çalışmaya mahkum ama benim
anlatmak istediğim Hikayeler var bu
hikayelerinin hepsi Türkiye'ye dair bu
hikayeler Zeki Müren'den Bülent Ersoy'un
dan Gülben Ergen'den Cüneyt arkın'a
kadar bu hikayeler 2019 gece kulübünden
Şan Tiyatrosu'nda
bu Atatürk Kültür Merkezi'nden daha
birçok farklı bizim toplumsal hafızamıza
işlemiş karakter mekan ve olaylar
hakkında çok fazla anlatılabilecek
hikaye var Ben balık hafızalı bir
toplumda yaşayan fil hafızalı bir çocuk
haline dönüştüm bütün bu o kulaklarımla
ve bunları gizli saklı yapmaktan ötürü
içselleştirme ile birlikte ve ben bu
hikayeleri anlatmak istiyorum dedim Ama
bunun için önceki Düzenli bir işe
ihtiyacım var o zaman Türkiye'ye dönüyor
Düzenli bir işim olsun Yanında da
belgesel işleri çekerim çok güzel hemen
olur rağmen Bülent Ersoy'un 70'li
yıllardaki rakibe si sahibinden Sultan
ile iletişime geçtim kendisi hakkında
bir belgesel çekmek istedim soyadım
kabul etti şifon kazandım Bununla ilgili
müracaatta bulup ve Türkiye'ye dönmeye
karar verdim döner dönmez linkedin'den
başvurumu yaptım kurumsal bir şirkette
kurucu olarak işe başladım bu kurumsal
şirketin YouTube a o sırada yeni
kuruluyordu bugün Türkiye'deki en
büyüklerinden biri oldular kendi
alanlarında ve ben o dönem o şirkette
yaka
ne yüzle 120 video arası çıkartan sadece
ben de bir stajyer olarak çalışıyorduk
bir kurucu oldum bu süreç içerisinde
İngiltere'den buraya dönerken Uçağım
Atatürk Havalimanı'na inmesi gerekirken
Esenboğa yerinde Çünkü Atatürk
Havalimanı'nda silahlı saldırı olmuştu
hemen birkaç hafta Sonrasında da
çalıştığım kurumsal şirkette 15 Temmuz
darbe girişimi ile beraber şirkete
girildi ve biz akabindeki Aylar Boyunca
o kırık kapıyla orada çalışmaya başladık
bana tanıştığım herkes Çünkü yeni bir
ortamda Aydın seneler sonra Türkiye
dedim ilk defa birlerine zaman çalış
tanışıyorum özellikle çalışma ortamında
Niye döndün Niye döndün Neden döndün her
gün bu soruyu sordu dinliyordum malum o
zamanlar gerçekten olaylar çok kötüye
gittiği içinde bütün toplumsal huzurumuz
kaçtı için bir çok trajik olayı üst üste
yaşadığımız için hep beraber giderek
benim oğlum düşmeye başladı Ben de niye
geldin niye geldin demeye başlamıştı o
tam
bu dinlemeye başladım günlerden Birinde
de sahibinden sultanı projeden
vazgeçeceği tuttu ve Rusya'da gerçekten
tutunduğum ve tutkuyla yapmak istediğim
tek işte elimden gitmiş oldu bende işte
bunun yerine işte oyuncak videoları
olsun makyaj videoları olsun Bilmem Ne
biberi yorum Challenge videoları olsun
gibi şeylerin kurularını yaparak
hayatımı idame ettirir bir halde buldum
kendimi Ben dedim ki Madem ben bu iş
yerinde çalışıyorum Madem bütün vaktimi
burada geçiyorum o zaman ben buradan bir
iş yaratmaya çalışacağım dedim ve
oturdum şok hop başlığıyla beraber
içerik yani böyle 7 8 saniye içerik Konu
başlığı listesi çıkarttım ve oradaki
müdürüme sundum O da sağ olsun yani asla
tatlı da bir insandır beni Mobilya karşı
korunmuşluğu da vardır fakat bana direkt
olmaz abi bu tutmazdı çok miniş mı
işledi Burada hiçbir şey çıkmaz yani
dedi Sen boş ver Takma kuru bunu
yaptırdı Ben de tamam dedim ama biraz da
koydu içine ve bir senenin sonunda orada
Bu karar verdim çünkü gerçekten sabah
6'da uyanıp sevmediğim bir işe gidip
akşam 6'da oradan çıkıp evime dönüp
güneş ışığı almayan bir odanın içinde
bütün gün çalışmak kimse için ideal
değil Özellikle İçimde yanan gerçekten
kendi içeriğimi üretme Ateşi var ve bir
şekilde insanlara ulaşmak istiyorum Ben
bu işten istifa ettim ve a noktasına
geri döndüm tekrar filan çalışmaya
başladım artık ülke değiştirmiştim
Geçmiş olsun İngiltere'deki oturun
başvuru yapmıştım ve bu final çalışmaya
başladığı sıralarda da bugün burada
konuşmacı olarak dinleyeceğiniz Gülben
Ergen'le ilgili olaylar silsilesi koptu
iş çığırından çıktı ve benim etrafımda
Bu konuyla ilgili gerçekten çok fazla
şey araştırmış ve biliyor olduğunu
düşünen bazı Eşim Dostum arkadaşım bana
baskı yapmaya başladı Yeter artık Sen ne
zaman bu iş yapacaksın diye ben Böylece
şubat ayının son
pes 2018'in şubat ayının sonlarında ilk
video hazırladım ilk videomu hazırlarken
sesini kaydetmiştim Fakat bu sunumun
nasıl olacağına dair gerçekten cesaretim
ve Bir fikrim o sırada gerçekten yoktu
Sadece ilk düğüm hatırlıyorum YouTube'da
çalıştığım için ve YouTube kanalları
işleri yaptığım için bir kanalım yüzünün
olmasındaki en önemli olduğunun
farkındaydım sadece bir sesten s ama bir
anlamda Merhabalar ben de ki macun Ben
magazin bir kişiyim Demek bana gerçekten
de zor geliyordu Ve Su geliyordu onu Bu
yüzden de maske kullanabilirim diye
düşündüm şubat ayının sonlarında Kadıköy
moda'daki evimizin salonunda Bu ilk
videomu çektim bu işe başladım ve Düşe
Kalka devam ederek şu an Bir seneye
doğru giderek yaklaşıyorum ekibimiz
büyüyor insanların iş imkanı
sağlayabiliyoruz ve benimle aynı tutkuyu
paylaşan insanlarla bir
tek bir kafa kafaya verip çok güzel
işler çıkarta biliyoruz ortaya
koyabiliyoruz popüler kültürün içinde
gerçekten hayatlarımızda dair kesitler
alışkanlıklarımıza dair kesitler bizim
toplumsal kodlarımız da dair çok önemli
böyle anahtar bilgiler hepsi bunun
içinde saklı magazinde İşte bunun için
güçlü yani bugün bir Zeki Müren'den söz
ettiğimizde altı tane 10 sene sığan bir
kariyerden mesela bahsediyoruz ve bu
6-10 seneye sağın kariyer içerisinde
Türkiye'nin de nasıl değiştiğini
görüyoruz Yani tuhaf bir şekilde
hepimizin ekonomik ilerle işimiz ve
akışınızı da takip edebiliyoruz magazin
üstünden politik olayların da takip
edebiliyoruz sanki hepsini birleştiren
bir türlü şemsiye sağlıyormuş bize gibi
ama ya buna dönüp de işte şunu
ahlakından bahsedeceğiz işte bunun
yaptığı işte bilmem ne yıkılmayacağız
noktasından yaklaşarak ya da ya bu
insanlar ne ki zaten işte kitlelerin
afyonu magazin boş kafaları doldurmak
için yapılmış bir şey gözüyle
o orada kalmaya mahkum bir şey ben bu
işi yapmaya başlamadan önce etrafında
sadece 3-5 tane arkadaşım benim magazin
konusunda Kara ilgili olduğunu biliyordu
yani ailemin yanında ya da işte böyle
çok iyi tanımadığım arkadaşlarımın falan
bulunduğu gruplarda magazin konular
açıldığında Ben bilmez numarasını
yapıyorum çünkü bildiğim belli ettiği
zamanlarda yediğim bakışları biliyorum
insanların Hayat andırıyor Peki niye
biliyorsun ki falan gibi şeyler
dediklerini verebiliyorum ve bu beni
gerçekten çok ötekileştirici çok Bak o
sosyal grubun dışına gitti E yani bir
insan dışarı geçileceğini ötekileştirici
bile bile neden bunu yapmak ister Ben
kendi içindeki tutkuya hakim olamadım
gibi Tam da öksürük gibi 30 ki hakim
olamadığım için bu yola çıktım Bugün
buradayım Ve burada olmaktan çok
mutluyum iyi ki burada maske çıkar
bu videoları maskeyle devam edecek
kendinize iyi bakın hoşça kalın
[Alkış]
[Müzik]